du kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen wie
chaotisch hier alles ist die arme lotter
das mit jonas hat sie wirklich hart
getroffen
ich brauche jemanden zum reden
ja ich kann ja nicht mal mit jonas
darüber reden wenn ich selber nicht weiß
was ich fühle
aus enttäuschung enttäuschung überall
naja
ganz egal was ich gerade an fast alles
läuft schief mein praktikum bei alex
mein job in der kneipe philipp beck hat
mich die ganze zeit an die flotte hast
jetzt noch ihre entwürfe weg und sie
glaubt wirklich dass ich sie habe ja
alles scheiße
genommen
hör mal ich habe gestern abend erfahren
dass vincent dich rausgeschmissen hat
ich wollte dir nur sagen ich glaube
nicht dass was geklaut hast danke ich
war das auch nicht
das geld muss irgendwie herausgefallen
sein oder vincent hat sich verrechnet
ich rede
vielleicht stellt sich hier wieder ein
das nett von dir aber ich weiß nicht ob
ich das überhaupt will
klar willst du dass schlaf dich erst mal
raus
richtig geweckt hat
ach so gestern war markiert ich habe ihn
rein gelassen als ich gegangen bin